hey guys dr. Burke here in this video
I'm going to show you how to correct a
short leg okay a lot of people are
walking on with a short leg and I'm
going to show you what not to do and
what to do
first of all there's a muscle deep
inside your your abdomen okay and it's
from the last rib to your hip bone
right through here it's called iliac
crest and you got two of them they're
these big broad muscles on both sides
they're in your back and they connect
the upper rib to this area right here
and it's called the quadratus lumborum
okay what happens a short leg is mainly
affected by one of these muscles it's
too tight maybe you fell on your
tailbone
maybe you fell in your butt real hard
and you jammed it and caused a spasm
okay so what happens is one of these
muscles will tighten up and draw up the
pelvis on one side now let's just
pretend it went up on this side that the
hip went higher it's going to make the
leg seem short on that side right so if
you're checking the leg lengths and you
have a short leg in your mind you might
think oh I'm going to give the person a
heel lift on the short leg well guess
what that's going to do it's going to
make it worse it's going to drive the
hip higher okay
so usually it's true that you could have
a short leg but it's very rare unless
you broke your leg but typically what
happens it's really a pelvis that draws
up on the side where it's short okay so
we're going to show you an exercise how
to fix that but the point is don't ever
put a heel lift in the short leg because
it might be the wrong side you should
put in the longer leg because it'll
drive up the hip right here and why
because the problem is actually a muscle
that's drawing it up and it's making it
appear to be short all right so let's
now show you what to do to fix this okay
so if we look at the short leg we got a
short leg on the left side over here
okay you can see that it's short and
that means that his pelvis is drawing
upward okay so we got a spasm on his
pelvis up to the is lower back so that
muscle the quadratus lumborum is too
tight on that side because it's drawing
up the worst thing you can do is put a
lift heel lift on the short leg why
because it's going to drive the pelvis
higher so this could happen from a fall
in the tailbone fall on the butt
whatever or on the knee and jam that
side so now the question is how do we
fix it right now I found that if you try
to stretch the short leg it doesn't work
because the thing is in a guarding mode
so it's kind of like taking an injured
muscle and stretching it just kind of
like a rubber band it comes right back
okay so there's a much simpler way and
it's using a technique to pull a muscle
out of that protect mode at that
guarding mode okay so we want to get it
to relax and what we're going to do is
we're going to actually work on the
opposite muscle so we're going to
stretch the opposite muscle okay so when
we stress the opposite muscle it's going
to send a signal to the short leg and
relax it why because both of those
muscles in your back work together
they're on the same electrical circuit
so what we're going to do is we're going
to work on the other side to fix the
short side okay sounds might sound new
to you but it really works so this is
what we're going to do we're going to
take the long leg okay and we're going
to stretch it downward towards me so
just push drop your pelvis down towards
me yes as far as you can push it yeah
right there good relax it good let's do
that again
good now look what we're doing we're
taking the long leg and making it worse
okay we're exaggerating the long leg
this is stretching the good side and
it's sending signals into the tight side
you'll see when we're done okay we're do
this 10 times and you can do this
yourself while laying in your body all
you need to help with this is for
someone to tell you what leg is short
okay okay good now so that's you do it
like 10 times so now what I'm going to
do is I'm going to recheck and you can
see the leg lengths are perfectly
balanced
it's an amazing so this is how you fix a
short leg go ahead make your comments
below and I will see you on the next
video